brian do you want to know about today's
sponsor go for it bro because you and i
are going
to the moon mobile especially for the
first time since the last one was in
fact
a hawks yes probably don't know if
that's the one we're going to talk about
today though it's a new innovative
mobile service
to the moon mobile it's it looks nice
it's easy to remember do the graphics
ttm as we're gonna call them is a
revolution among uk
mobile operators and it's the first
network to a flexible
bundled choice i know what you mean
there's a lot of it's very you pick your
package you stick to it yeah exactly not
with the sick of that there's a little
thing you can go
oh oh oh on the app really yeah just
slide over yeah slide around so not only
that i love sliding in they also have a
crypto wallet
which is your guide into the world of
cryptocurrency it's about time i've got
on the gravy training see all these
youtubers oh i'm buying
whatever 90 years they've made any money
this is where the big lad comes right
okay now i don't know about you but i
don't like being tied down to a contract
i like being tied down but not to a
contract yeah on ttm
they allow you flexibility so on the app
you can basically go
i do like that just switch it up and
know that with free uk calls and
messages
it's easy to find the bundle just for
you do i want to pay for my calls and
messages
no thank you very much thank you ttm but
you also get to keep your existing
numbers so you know sometimes you swap
contracts and they go uh
oh i'm going to give you a new number
with that i've got a real bad memory as
well so that helps
their cryptocurrency wallet on your
mobile is fast and it's more importantly
secure storing up to 18 types of
currency yeah with quick withdrawals
i didn't even there's one thing i like
it's a quick pull out yeah right
the great thing is you can view the
rates in dynamics you can also top up
the crypto wallet from a bank account or
from another crypto wallet
and exchange one cryptocurrency for
another and starting
is very easy just for registering and
going through the verification process
you can get a hundred quid
put in your account yep and the amount
of pounds that you get is completely
random so it's absolutely fair you might
register to get a hundred you get
something up to that look how much i got
money for nothing and if there's one
thing i like in life it's that
right yeah so you can try your luck as
well and you might be able to forget
about top up for a little while so if
you want to try it out click the link in
the description below and get your
bundle from to the moon mobile but for
now
it's time for true news
just when you think you've got true news
in the cam then a super exhibition comes
along to change your day
genuinely last night we were about
upload true news and then
it broke logan paul versus
floyd money mayweather super exhibition
whatever that means what the [__] does
it mean brian i had to google floyd
mayweather mayweather turns out he's
sort of a boxer from the 90s
very famous man he also played one of
the ninja turtles which is why he's got
the
branding all over him i'm really excited
to see him in the ring and see if he can
withstand
logan's onslaught phil god knows how
many rounds in this
super exhibition um i just want to say
well done logan well done
you secured the bug you could film the
kick off for eight years this this is
the biggest thing to happen to youtube
ever
ever ever that's it sorry but equally
the other way
this is the biggest thing ever to happen
to floyd mayweather this will be up
there in floyd's list of most watched
fights this will be top three it'll be
nearly four years by the time he fights
since he's had a fight it's against
a youtuber who lost his last fight his
only profile he's only pro fight so the
last time floyd four was against an o
boxer in conor mcgregor and
bear in mind conor mcgregor had you know
world titles under his belt in mma logan
paul
fought ksi didn't win and now he's
fighting
floyd mayweather like you know 2020 was
a bit of a it's been a weird yeah i
really never thought
we'd be still in december saying i just
can't believe this i can't believe this
this is not a good look for floyd
mayweather at all in my opinion
when you're a pro fighter known as one
of the greatest ever and you've got to
then make money by fighting
people who and let's be clear are not
professional boxers
logan paul is not a professional boxer
he's had one other fight with the guy
who was also
not a pro boxer having a pro fight does
not make you a pro boxer having 20 wins
as a pro boxer
makes you a pro boxer right this is what
floyd mayweather dedicated
his life to and the fact that he comes
out of retirement to fight an
entertainer people are drinking the
mayweather kool-aid
so much that they will just ignore the
all of these facts
do you really think floyd is a great
businessman because he's doing this to
make money now this is like
circus type [__] i'm starting to think
that great businessman actually means
the opposite of what people
because you know there are there are
many people in america who go he is a
great businessman
you just find out they're just tossers
floyd literally has made hundreds of
millions of pounds
by boxing and he claims then that's my
investments
it's my investments 50 cent called this
years ago when he became very good
friends with him he said that man spends
money
like it's going out of fashion he will
be fighting until it's [__] 50 years
old bear in mind what does he know
seven years left 43 oh he will actually
he will literally be celebrating his
birthday days after fighting
logan 44 not what you do when you've
made all that money and you're
comfortable and you don't need to make
any more
you don't risk 50 and all against an
entertainer who is twice the size of you
for the laughs the guy is clearly
spending a lot of [__] money and he's
doing this
because he needs money if you don't
believe that i can't help you
question i just can't [__] help and i
don't think you can help these people
anyway do you think there's actually
count towards the record
because it's a super exhibition it won't
it won't even be 50 in one
however you're getting in there with a
way bigger guy if logan paul buys some
fluke and when punches are flying
anything can happen
if logan paul connects and knocks out
floyd mayweather and
mark my [__] words unless the rules
are all in [__] flights forever we
don't know what the [__] and how we'll
get myself into
when a man logan's size hits a man
floyd's size
a knockout can quite easily occur so to
risk all that
for oh he just wants to secure the bag
no he should already have done that this
shouldn't even be necessary
i really wonder what pro boxing fans
will think of this because they they
hated ksi versus logan because of all
the attention this got
now your king now one of the goats
is forcing you guys to literally be
dragged back into this but now you've
got someone on the line
you can't ignore it youtube's kind of
taking over boxing it's [__] insane
jake paul was the main [__] thing
that people cared about over a mike
tyson card
no one gave a [__] afterwards about mike
tyson it was all about what jake paul
did those are facts
is this gonna be logan basically saying
to him like the boxing community don't
respect you
this is undermining you why have you had
to take this fight you're a [__]
idiot for doing this and at the same
time being like there's a chance i catch
you and you go down
plotting those seeds the boxing
community just took a
very deep breath because they're going
to be thinking what if
floyd loses to a [__] youtuber they
don't want that no one in boxing
wants that but guess what i want that
right i want logan paul
to decimate mayweather in the [__]
head
collapsing him on the ring out [__]
cold i will get up on this [__] table
i will be s dancing on the grave of
floyd mayweather making a note here
reinforce table i am going to laugh my
[__] [__] off if this happens live
live we will be live he will remove his
penis
live february february the 20th
2021 so anyone out there that sponsors
blades brian's gonna laugh his [__] off
in 2021 if you want to be the blade that
helps me remove that penis
get in touch all right we've hyped it up
what actually happened that's the real
issue
mayweather in his last fight comfortably
beat conor mcgregor mcgregor came at him
he let him punch himself out a bit
then he came on later on in the rounds
and he stopped them he looked good
he didn't look primarily by any means
not as quick as he used to be
not quite as sharp as he used to be but
still very good logan on the other hand
had a fight against another youtuber
logan looked probably technically a bit
better than ksi but ksi had that
aggression and that fighting mentality
and came after him and obviously there
was a point deduction as well
overall logan wasn't landing enough
punches
to be considered at a pro boxer level i
felt like a lot of those later rounds i
was just looking thinking
you're not landing enough here you're
not being aggressive enough your
accuracy isn't quite there
timing isn't quite there floyd's head
movement and just general movement is
going to be way better than ksi so this
is
a big issue it's going to be very
difficult for him in the time
since that fight by a lot of accounts
logan hasn't been boxing a lot whereas
even if floyd hasn't been boxing a lot
because he's been doing it since he was
a baby
he'll be back where he was pretty
quickly logan on the other hand has
very short amount of time to come up
with a strategy in order
to beat floyd mayweather i never thought
i'd be saying these [__] words
no i never thought i'd be saying things
i never thought i'd be saying this i
think the best strategy is jake in a wig
jake does look good in his last fight
yeah so the size difference
is massive we're talking five foot six
and a half versus
six foot three and a half mayweather 150
pounds
logan 200 pounds yes the skill is
completely different
but mayweather is used to fighting other
smaller guys logan
is huge you got to use your reach you
got to use your job in my opinion
the jab of logan is what could
potentially
win him this fight because you haven't
got all the time in the world to [__]
make
it like mayweather is not going to hit
that hard for logan to take trust me on
this
later on in the rounds if logan tires
out etc well that might be a factor
but early on every advantage in terms of
physicality
is with logan that reach he has to make
that count because i don't think
conor came in with a good strategy conor
came in and put all of the pressure on
himself
to take the fight to mayweather what
logan needs to do mentally i think
before this fight is goes to me whether
you're the boxer come and knock me out
if i sit here and do nothing
you're the one who looks like an idiot
because you can't beat me you're the one
who should be beating
me mentally get the pressure on
mayweather to take the fight to him
mayweather is as his best when he's
being defensive and countering you
so if you can make him come at you a
little bit more you might have a bit
more success
i know that floyd mayweather's far more
intelligent in a boxing room than me
this is just the ideal scenario for a
friend of logan who wants to win this
fight well call him privately and tell
him that you don't need to tell him in
front of
millions of people they want to hear
this right don't over commit don't fight
on the inside as soon as he comes near
you throw that [__] jab he needs to
be throwing that jab out
every few seconds it needs to be there
constantly try and get a decision when
don't even worry about a [__] finish
this is all on mayweather put all the
pressure on him
he's the pro he's the legend and if you
can outland him
or at least look decent you've won the
fight i mean
whether or not you actually win or not
who gives a [__] if you make floyd
mayweather
look crap in any way you've won right
this basically just makes
logan paul the biggest star on youtube
by the way like
um it just does the biggest thing a
youtuber has ever done you know i'm not
not in anyone else you've got ksi who's
took it to new levels pewdiepie
all of these big youtubers have done
great things this is out of this world
you know he's gone mainstream like when
him in ksi for
like a lot of people in the
entertainment industry boxing and she
covered it but this is
the whole world will be talking about
logan paul now credit room it's [__]
amazing and if his brother's anything to
go by
well it's going to be a good fight jake
paul recently knocked out
nate robinson you're all seeing
it's a problem because the world's
problem child yeah
not just because it was nba or youtube
everyone
outside of that story because it was on
a mike tyson undercard and turns out
mike tyson is quite famous
so he has the problem jake paul stole
the [__] show
the whole thing was quite uh wishy-washy
that main event was was fixed but anyway
should we
should we watch you're right boxing hero
chin by
my mind youtube here we sing here our
heroes right against each other yeah
i'm not sure okay there was a lot of
that a lot of locking up do you think
jake initiated that or no
i think the minute nate got near him he
didn't really know what he was doing so
he was like just grab a hold of him
quite happy to be there in a way see
here he's throwing a little bit
but his hands are just in the middle of
[__] no way keep your hands up
rule number one that's a basketball rule
as well always be ready for the ball
so receiver the thing is he did receive
a big blow to the head right about now
bang ah just keep being honest after
re-watching the fight
the referee should have ended it right
about now thanks so brother
about now why should now at this point
nate robinson is claiming he's been
hitting the back of the head and he's a
bit annoyed about it there's a problem
he wasn't hitting the back of the head
he was hitting the side of him yeah and
the referee gave him
way more than the 10 seconds that you're
supposed to have
nate robinson face first down on the
canvas he doesn't look as good
he's going to beat the couch that was at
least an extra second on the six count
well i've got to go around you to count
another cone nba
jake paul oh dear me turn around turn
around you want to continue nick
come here at this point you wave this
off immediately no he is not fit to keep
on fighting no
not in nate's house you see this is
where you see the massive experience
difference yeah
jake is fainting nate is doing nothing
nothing
jabbed boom just massive difference in
experience
he's been given every opportunity by
referee thomas taylor
he's looking like a dispirited figure
they're in the boxing ring
and again this should have been called
off then as a referee it's your job to
make sure
especially new boxers who've never done
this before don't get
knocked out cold obviously you can't
help if it's a one shot but when you're
clearly seeing multiple knockdowns and
giving them longer time
you're asking for this [__] and it's
quite clear that nate is doing this
tonight for the very first time people
have died in the ring you know it's your
[__] job to make sure that this [__]
doesn't happen lovely little combination
from jake you have to finish the fight
jab body shot
lovely and he's out cold that's a sad
moment isn't it
nate robinson you picked this fight
let's not forget this
everyone's feeling sorry for for nate he
was the one who was i'm a proper athlete
i'm gonna show this youtube [__]
how real men fight well you just got
smoked
everyone said tonight i'm fighting for
my brothers in the nba
well they athletes across the world and
most importantly my
children did you hear what jake paul
said before the fight i'm gonna eat your
children
no no he said um just to nate's kids
please don't watch the fight because i'm
going to violently knock your dad out
and they went we love youtube harsh like
it's pretty harsh
i kind of like it though as an
entertainment side of things it's a good
light
and it was truthful he told the truth
well yeah this frame is going to be
famous forever now for jake paul
knocking out a real athlete that's the
point here that people aren't getting i
think a lot of people are criticizing
can you not get in your thick skull
a lot of people are criticizing jake
paul going well you only not oh
yeah and it's like yeah but he's a
youtuber
youtubers don't knock people out cold
this is the first
knock out called youtube fight we've
seen that's why this is impressive yeah
nate robinson was shy but the bottom
line is
he's quick he's fast and he moves like
an athlete at least there is some
form of test in front of jake paul he
passed it with flying colours
it doesn't mean he's the best boxer ever
but it does mean he
has been more deadly in his punching
ability in the last two fights than
anything we've seen
until this point from youtubers we
watched 12 rounds of logan vs ksi and
they weren't able to hurt each other the
way jake has been able
to brutally finish his last two
opponents
that being said logan and ksi are much
bigger
and much stronger i would say and so
maybe they would just better match with
each other right so now what we're
looking for from
jake is a better stronger match-up it
seems like the ksi
fight is likely i was sort of sick of
youtube boxing a little while ago
this [__] i want to see this [__] yeah i
i must admit it's uh it's exciting let's
go champ i'm ready to say that again
let's go champ it wouldn't surprise me
if we see ksi versus jake paul at the
end
of next year ksi's got a big tour in the
middle of the year he's going to want to
get through that he's going to want to
train he's obviously got a lot of work
to put in he's been training
i think in order to beat jake paul a
good year under his belt would be
brilliant for him thank you
in the meantime jake paul has been
calling out some mma fighters obviously
conor mcgregor could happen someday but
that ain't gonna happen anytime soon
connor's busy
trying to get his ufc belt back there's
ben askren who is
not a good puncher dylan danis who i
don't know how good he is he's conor
mcgregor's training partner he's a
brazilian jiu jitsu
legend but in his mma fight he didn't
look great on the feet and he's great at
[__] talking
that would again give jake more
credibility if he was to fight him
and beat him you're beating conor
mcgregor's training partner a
legend brazilian jiu-jitsu and a current
mma fighter that would be amazing a guy
who's at least
in the ballpark of having been in a
fighting scenario before loads of times
right
it feels like no matter what jake does
there's always going to be someone
sitting around the corner waiting to
take away from it that being said
i do think both logan and jj could beat
him it just depends on what happens in
the next 12 months who's putting in the
work
do you remember memes we can see some of
the memes i want you
beat it up and put me to sleep oh you
want that nate robinson
oh my god
whatever shows how much i'll give a [__]
are we kicking a man while he's down
here lauren here's the here's the real
thing i don't think when someone's been
knocked out it's the best thing to pile
in on them and be like ha
ha loads of people who wouldn't want to
say someone like out of the shame of it
do
something to themselves however we are
talking about a grown man
who knew what he was getting himself
involved in was heavily paid for that
and severely underestimated jake poland
actually dismissed him as an opponent
multiple types right nate robinson
yeah can i get a big mac
or what do you
not have big macs we have them we have
them
yeah what you gonna do if i don't
jake then called out ksi um in a weird
sort of nightclub moment with his mother
sup [__] i don't know why
it's funny that's so not an english
thing to do no
it's sort of a sup [__] most english
grandmas or mothers go she went
yeah you're scared bro i know you are
i'm a real dog i just became the biggest
prize fighter overnight a-side
feels good to be on the a side he's
saying he's the a side he's the biggest
role it's interesting because i think
in terms of the rest of the world that
viral clip of him knocking out nate
robinson
will have raised his stock he still
doesn't do the views
that ksi or logan do while he can
probably
make more waves in the sport of boxing
is he the a side i think that
he's not the a side in that regard he is
still going to have to split whatever he
makes
50 50. best yeah with ksi yeah but also
that's because
part of the draw here is that he is
fighting another youtuber who's of the
same size as him and
he's going to be an interesting you need
each other yeah so there isn't an a side
but i get what he means in terms of his
stocks rising
he was the um undercard to logan and jj
he's become
on their level through performances
rather than views
i really like logan's reaction you know
some brothers jealous of the other
brother this brother
we was hanging off parkway how the [__]
we on park south has caught him out of
my driveway got money coming here five
ways would you do this if i knocked
someone out yeah i'd get you all the
sort of
all of that would you cut a video like
this though where i'm up on your
shoulders and you're like
i feel like we just go for a curry or
something instead yeah we're quite
low-key in that sense
yeah we still put the music over
any more naan bread back there please
yeah yeah let's call mendel
yeah four peshwari nuns peshwari yes
please oh
yeah what about allergies we don't care
interesting
someone else thank you i've got an
allergy to losing you know conor
mcgregor dylan dennis
i'm gonna knock them both out so tell me
what happens if jake paul
fights conor mcgregor well jake paul has
two
wins in boxing conor mcgregor has one
loss maths you can't argue
jake paul wins easy mcgregor's won so
many fights
by knockout in mma against world-class
opponents all right that isn't just
boxing but these guys have been doing
stand-up for decades he then goes into
his first ever boxing match against
arguably the greatest of all time
lasts half an hour mayweather you know
eventually beat him and it did look
quite comfortable in the end
but still he did very well and he walks
around at about 170 pounds jake paul the
only advantage he has is he's bigger and
stronger
and not by a massive amount what is he
uh
18 pounds heavier that's that is a lot
but mcgregor would just dance around him
and eventually pick him apart
and beat him and knock him out in my
opinion knock out you're saying he'd
knock him out yeah it's like
it sounds shocking to say knock out but
actually it's not that shocking because
conor mcgregor is a fighter
the guy is professional yeah like jake
paul is just starting to learn something
that mcgregor has already been learning
for over 10 years you're just not going
to make that time up in the time that
you've got
i admire jake for winning the fight
because it would be a massive money
maker for him he'd be thinking i'm the
bigger stronger guy if i do
land i might hurt him i might knock him
out and it's conor mcgregor so all of
the chips would be stacked
in jake paul's favor because if he loses
he lost to conor mcgregor
if he wins you [__] beat the biggest
name in fighting
that's why jake paul is acting conor
mcgregor going like that
that is why he's constantly talking
about him because it puts him in the
conversation it makes him relevant and
it's only going to make him more money
and that's the same reason why conor
mcgregor has not responded in any way
shape or form because for him there's
nothing to gain here by piss-farting
around
with youtubers the reason floyd's doing
it is because floyd
can't fight top level boxers anymore
he's too
pasty and he'd get chinned he wants to
dance around with these youtubers and
potentially make some money mcgregor's
still trying to win world titles
you still want to see it there don't you
want to see i still buy you my money
we're buying it make it a buyer but the
fight they make
is ksi versus jake paul and i give
both guys a good shot at each other i
feel like we've got enough
paul oh yeah yeah actually logan did
break up with josie
what y'all ever see a victoria's secret
model riding a razor you swear
swear what that you won't flip me swear
i'm not gonna flip you oh i will be
upset
real upset so this is uh logan and josie
canseco now her dad is a famous baseball
player all right i get it is that why
she comes from good stocks good stock
yeah so they can basically hit balls
really well and there's this like
romantic moments up there yeah it's
basically best moments if you're
watching best of probably turn off now
we don't want to
i've got to admit my couples crush on
youtube probably these two i'm more of
you love them i'm more of a logan josie
you're more of a mic
you're not really a victoria's secret
model kind of guy brian doesn't go for
pencils he goes for marcus do you know
what i mean
yeah i almost
these two look great together amazing
but i just i never seen that being the
end thing
logan's gonna have like a life where he
just goes through like woman after woman
after woman
i can't see him settling down until he's
like 40. i'm gonna be honest here brian
my projecting i think you're projecting
yeah
so anyway they're broke off anyway
here's the podcast where they broke up
yeah
yeah i mean i don't i didn't really plan
yeah i'm sorry
but also like how are we gonna do that
well mike we know how you're gonna do
that
with tears in your eyes on your own not
like this to be fair you absolutely
nailed that video though he smashed it
yeah if you're going to make money off a
breakup that's ideal
what i find amazing how he moves these
girls on one
after the other afternoon he moves them
on and it's like one day they're just
not here anymore and no one ever asked
any
questions this man is the untouchable by
the way
he is teflon yeah the way he just come
on then
boom boom boom all right three months
see you next one
victoria's secret model come on down
progressive news in a way you might
remember the film juno you might also
remember the film
inception star of that elliot page we
will now call him
has become transgender this is an act
oscar nominee
yeah this is an oscar-nominated actor
who's changing their gender
you're [__] up by picking elliot if i
was going to become a woman i'd become
like you know
such a [__] name so if you were going to
go the other way you wouldn't just go oh
brianna do you know what i mean that
would be stupid
i actually like brianna so i probably
would go that way okay well i just
i'd love to be a woman i'm sorry i don't
know why
no it's just my problem is i'd be lauren
boring
and don't at lauren alexis it's a what
about you know those things where they
can change your face into
a woman have you ever done that side
sidemen did it didn't they okay so let's
have a have a talk about which is the
prettiest sidemen
member right as a woman zerka definitely
wouldn't look like that as a woman quite
pretty i mean not too bad is that josh
he looks kind of nice you know as a
female
harry oh my god harry looks um like
hermione cray in each other no
worse harry's that friend that you go
worse yeah europe good friend
good personality yeah vic looks
fantastic yeah vic looks great
definitely better as a woman that's so
mean what makes a good looking guy
yeah but that's an upgrade oh yeah the
hair definitely is
a massive just tell me what you're
[__] put the mirror yeah yes or no
brian put the makeup
on right we'll think about it right it
looks like a little bit of a painting
you know
yeah that's i mean even circus sort of
confused by it young minds will want
their logo removed from that
simon is a distinctly average woman i'm
just going to be honest i think he looks
a bit like sort of a
librarian there or something yeah
awkwardly i think i've been with someone
who looks quite like that
do we do ours or not how do we do ours
oh bro you're the tech [__] geek i
haven't got a clue
a few moments later you're quite hot
this does not look like me laura
that's you it looks like it's you it
looks like logan paul's dad more than it
looks like me
exactly it's you as a woman can i take
another photo this sure doesn't look
like this okay
i can't believe that you're posing
thinking that this is gonna make the
outcome better
look at your [__] beard i want to
look like the pretty me
and you can't stop me tail as old as
time
are you saying i look like the beast no
here's the thing
people will say you look like the beast
when actually i've got an image of you
looking like
belle no but even as a woman i look like
a man i can't even be a woman if i
wonder
can we see you now prick no no i'm just
going to use the spice girls
that's amazing you look sexy
i don't know why this is so funny i
would look horrific as a woman is what
we found out here
like we both look like too manly for the
[__] to work right yeah that's
such alpha [__] males i want to see
him look like his camera and diaz
it's just mentally wow look at that just
to finish on earlier page we're very
supportive
of this it's easy to trivialize someone
going from being a woman not to being a
man
i wasn't trivializing that i just want
to see what i would look like right but
it's a huge life decision and i've got
to admit i think it's positive
after seeing ourselves as women we're
both having second thoughts so we
realize
how serious this is for someone what was
nice about this statement is that
there's been a lot of acknowledgement on
the actual
hardship that people who are trans
suffer in 2020 alone it's reported that
at least
40 transgender people have been murdered
so while this could have all have been
about
elliot's um transition into being a man
it's actually a lot of it is while this
spotlight is on me
i'm going to divert it to stuff that
actually needs talking about and now
we're talking about it
i feel like because i really could give
two shits what people
are what they want sexually what what
they class themselves
you forget that there's a lot of people
out there who still really do not only
care about this but hear people for what
they're into or what their
choices are and um it's ridiculous yeah
it doesn't impact you at all really
20 20 minutes yeah i mean there's more
important things to [__] worry about
than what people
want to do with their organs i can just
imagine a lot of those people sort of
bursting in for home when these people
are about to have sex with someone else
again oh you can't
no way don't pop knob in a yeah
not in the ass or in the fanny that
they've you know what if
they've got they can pop it wherever
they want do it ultimately you could
[__] armpit for a weekend do you know
what i mean you have a choice
it's a crisp you ever tried it's a
christmas you ever tried a knee some
people put the feet together and then
sort of like that yeah sort of like a
foot vagina in a sense or a foot [__]
never thought of it now
never but now tonight's uh tonight's the
foot night the world is your oyster
the world is your feet did you say the
world is your feet
oh i just want to say before we move on
well done to the side men as well but
because we did mention them there they
hit 10 million subscribers on their
channel they've helped us out over the
years we've had a lot of banter with
them but we do love them
so well done well we've had a lot of
banter with them ball wipes
that's how we're going to start oh bro
you got some crusty balls
imagine your balls smelling like that
genuinely that's quite nice that isn't
that's a good sense but it goes down
there but it isn't scented scented so
like
i'm gonna be honest if someone was to
say go near them afterwards
in intercourse they're not going to be
like oh i'm not licking that that's like
perfume
yeah no it's very natural it's feasible
that your balls would smell like this
go and do it well in half an hour it
takes a lot of
yeah i'm a two wiper wow
you're a double wiper yeah you do the
front and the back at least
one per ball i suppose this is called
the weed whacker do you know how you do
that you just
i was planning on keeping that as oh you
well that's the great thing all you need
to do is do that and that gets rid of
all the hair well could you not empty
your
hair put some of your nose out under my
[__] table where's my side of the
desk oh do you eat dinner over we
were actually messaging in the middle of
the week or in this weed whacker is
pretty good in it do you know the thing
with landscape i just i don't need to do
anything anymore like i don't need to go
to the barbers or out you know
just do my hair do my [__] everything
i'm good
this is the lawnmower 3.0 3.0
honestly i didn't think they could
improve it but they bought this one out
they've done it they've developed it
they're like us they keep leveling up
they keep leveling up
do you see this here look look at this
you see that it's got a light on it yeah
do you know why
so you can see what you're shaving well
you know sometimes you look down and
you're like a bit dark in this
bathroom under this sack not anymore so
i just want to say genuinely we do
actually love manscape they're a great
brand very easy to work with for us
quality products we couldn't be happier
if you guys
want to get in on your manscape action
then the link
is manscape.com true for 20
off and free shipping that's fantastic
20 off from free shipping you couldn't
ask for any more you
can look just like us if you knew how
these looked you would be so impressed
right listening
either of us are wearing trousers thank
you
back to true news so the good news if we
do want to go to america alone there's a
vaccine now for kovitz
you get that pop that in your ass or
wherever else you want to put it in the
arm
in the arm now as you may have noticed
the government are actually quite proud
of this because britain they're the
first country in the world to have it
brian the first country why are we the
first let's let the actual government
who went on the [__] radio to
announce this have a bit of a victory
lap all right finally
the government has done something right
let's hope they can lose gavin
williamson a guy who obviously is an
expert in medicine as he's the education
secretary well i i just reckon we've got
the very best people in this country and
we've obviously got the best medical
regulators much better than the french
have much better than the belgians have
much better than the americans have
that doesn't surprise me at all because
we're much better country than every
single one of them
that's right okay sorry just be
absolutely clear gavin you know when you
go on the radio and you have a good
interview when you get excited at the
end and they go gavin we're going to let
you go in a minute you've got to keep
the veneer up mate
you can't just go absolutely we're
better than america the people we're
going to try and trade with from now on
didn't go down well in america
he's literally handing this guy an open
goal he's going mate all you need to say
now is
brexit was great brexit really helped
even though we haven't got a deal and
nick ferrari can go brilliant gavin
williamson thank you very much goodbye
gavin williams goes no
we're better than everyone
good old adolf had a similar attitude
look how well that worked out
people in this country are going to be
the first ones in the western world to
get that
fire or in the world to get that
pharisee vaccine
real competitive advantage you know what
it is and that's what i love about it
and that's what this government is
always measuring
how can we get a competitive advantage
the citizens all right doesn't matter do
we have the competitive advantage on the
rest of the world i know what i think
when i think of a vaccine i think is
this going to give us the competitive
advantage in the business market well
yeah because we'll be more alive than
that
yeah exactly we'll be there'll be more
people alive quite literally than the
people who don't have the vaccine and
you know what that's something to
celebrate [__] them
yeah people are dying in other countries
but we aren't and that's good
i really feel a bit bad because we do
have a lot of fans from around the world
who are tuning in right now yeah and it
pains me to say no we're better than you
what's better that's not us saying that
that's our government
saying that all right who will we
disagree yeah and the government they've
never been swept about by anything right
these guys
have been totally reasonable and level
headed all the way through there is one
problem
it would appear that boris might not
have been completely truthful about some
other things
that's not true no this might shock you
no you remember paul boris had the
microwave ready brexit absolutely what
the oven ready one as well
it's ready for anything yeah well this
woman in um the
eu she basically thinks we're getting
[__]
so boris johnson has been lying to the
people
in the uk the 350 million pounds for the
nhs
after brexit no customs checks between
northern ireland and the rest of the uk
we're the best we're the best we're the
ones
we can go off and invade other countries
again now it's what we do
best she doesn't want to hear her i
don't want to hear it no
boris johnson did a good job he found
the better science brian do you remember
this
ready one two three go food reviewer
all right so the people that get me the
stuff to try they got me uh auntie
spotted dick it should be uncle's
spotted dick all right why does auntie
have dick that does not make sense to me
i love him already there you go not
really even too sure what this is
i mean it looks like all right it smells
alright i smelt it it does not smell
like dick
it doesn't look great do you like
spotted dick or not what is that
it's like a pudding with um raisins in
and stuff i'm not a big fan
i like pudding
oh god that really doesn't look
appetizing like that does it it looks
like some sort of jelly thing that comes
out with like a dog
dish it looks a little bit caramelised
i'll give you that does not really
resemble a dick at all
who would i or you know how would i know
you do have one he's really defensive
deliciously moist spotted dick steamed
puddings
with sultanas and raisins i don't know
what a sultana is
i think you're going to love them so
talas are nice
this is not bad you can really hear his
mouth can't you in this
i like that i like the mouth so i want
to feel like i'm in the room yeah but
you don't want to have the
no the food guy you do it's not about
being polite it's about really
feeling like you're there yeah but i can
see him chewing i don't need him to
audibly tell me yeah don't do that
yes uh you get this this is like a
british thing
so and there's a lot of british or
european british people that watch this
yeah
he's finally acknowledged yes you're
welcome finally acknowledging that's
this thing we'll get a shout out by the
way it's time for uh blue van man
we have come to starbucks and we are
going to review a couple of things what
we're going to review for things as a
matter of fact
have you got a different drink to me
i've got a different drink you've got
the uh eggnog latte eggnog
that is good that's got a yeah there's
just something about dave
it's so enchanting about him so animated
this is so charismatic
literally he is i think he's better than
carl pilkington i think he's actually
like another level that is a big shout
out you know what i mean it's a big
shout out
and here's the thing i'll give dave
credit for youtubers generally when they
don't edit their stuff they're very very
boring no character
a handful of youtubers out there can
carry long-form stuff they're always
entertaining
very few of us very few of us we're an
exclusive club dave's in that club
though
he's three he's always entertaining it
doesn't matter how long you spend with
them how long are you watching it's very
rare where you go
this is getting boring now nutmeg yeah
you're getting the nutty nutmeg
a little bit nutty little bit nutty
that's nice but i prefer the eggnog yeah
what made this better is a bit of wazzy
cream on the top
wouldn't it can't we scoop you i'm not
saying anything
i knew dave would make a joke about
creaming in his van again
see this is love letting a nicky cream
letting her have me cream
oh another innuendo what i want to see
ideally
is some sort of flavor man christmas
dinner thing
i want to watch them brilliant have
their christmas dinner oh god
could you film it for us guys please
um that was true news guys uh it's been
a fun one thanks a lot for spending time
with us we really appreciate it hit the
subscribe button hit the like button
all of that [__] oh hit the links for
the sponsors because you really need to
impress them
also we'll see you on twitch when we're
live catch you soon
see ya